um
i mean he cleans he doesn't remember
anything or raped me
and i don't even know how to take that
we've been together 11 years you know
what happens when after 11 years someone
just stopped scaring it's hard to
process
all right amber yes amber where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
charleston west virginia i grew up when
tyler mountain a very
um low-class
community
and tell me about your childhood you had
both mom and dad growing up yes i had
mom and dad um
dad was pretty
you know he was there but he wasn't
there um he was a
violent alcoholic well if he drank beer
he was okay but when he started drinking
liquor it was bad i mean it got to the
point where you know weapons came out
um he had break broke my mom's ribs
he would start to fight with my brother
and then eventually he would he would
fight with me
and um
the last time before he he's sober now
but the last time he i don't know why my
brother let him in our apartment he had
a knife and my daughter was so scared
she peed herself
and how would you describe your
childhood
um i have good memories
but
i had to grow i grew up fast you know
i didn't really have a normal childhood
ever you know
my parents didn't protect me from things
um
i was the only one
only girl um ever my dad had
four brothers they all had boys i was
the only girl
um
that you can imagine that was uh i was
the youngest and that created some
problems um
you know they uh
i i suffered some trauma in my childhood
you know i think it affects me more than
i realize what kind of stuff are you
talking about um
just um sexual stuff
um
you know um within your family yes food
in the family and
outside the family food insecurity you
know
my mother trying to
you know um
[Music]
get me to sleep with men
um to feed her
habit as well oh really
i'm sorry that's all right
what was your high school
south charleston high school what were
your high school years like um it was
good
it was my um high school wizard i was a
uh
it was a refuge for me i went to a
my elementary school was all white and
then i went to dunbar junior high which
was 70 black and and it was culture
shock you know
but then um
i only went there for two years
and then um
when i went to south charleston uh
it was it was good you know i've always
been really good academically i had a
full scholarship to
pennsylvania culinary institute
and i didn't go
i didn't go maybe because i was afraid
of failure i'd been told that my whole
life
and
i decided to get married to high school
sweetheart instead that that worked out
really well
he ended up
hitting on me and we uh
separated in
2011 when my daughter thank you when my
daughter was two
and that's when i was met my current
well i had met my current special our
partner when i was 18
and um but we got together in 2011
and
it's been good it's been bad and now
it's kind of undetermined i don't i
don't know where we stand
how many how many children do you have i
have three you have three mm-hmm and
you're raising
one one of them
the other two or where they are with um
my partner's mother she's adopted them
which i'm
we have our differences but i respect
her because she loves my children and
she takes care of them they want for
nothing
so
so drugs started for you at what age um
12 15
yeah who introduced you to drugs at that
age um
everyone around me i mean i used to um
your mom was using
yeah but it might also my friend she um
her mother
um was on the old school like um
biker
crank methamphetamine and um she would
get beat if she you know you did it to
clean you know and she would get beat
otherwise
and then um she
my
best friend's mother growing up um kind
of sold her daughter to the neighbor
um
for um p for t which i understand is pcp
angel dust now i didn't even know so at
that young age we were doing
you know hard hard drugs that i wonder
how they affect me now
and where are you living today um i live
when
i live in an apartment with
my mom
my
partner
and my son solomon he is my joy
how many people get to raise their
guardian angel you know he saved my life
and looking back at your life what is
your biggest regret
not having my children
and i i think that my daughter thinks
that i tried harder
for my son solomon
you know to keep him
but the truth matter was i wasn't given
the chance you know and i got out of
jail
and
my rights were terminated
so
for paraphernalia and i had no no
no criminal history no and they dropped
it but i still didn't it's been expunged
but i still my children didn't get their
time back you know
my son yeah he regressed he's
only seven in april
i don't even really know him he was
three when he got taken and he stayed up
for four days looking for us
so
what is your drug today
opiates
pills or heroin pills
generally heroin if i can't find it um
yeah
i'm i'm working on going back to the
suboxone doctor but the problem is now i
don't have a ride i had a we had a
vehicle but
on the night when i was going over to
get something for us to feel better um i
slipped on ice and i
corrected but then i over corrected it
and i hit a ditch and i spun around i
broke the spindle off
and like 300 damage but it might as well
be a million
so yeah
and it's in nitro so right now i don't
have a
i have a way there it's i thought we've
tried walking but it's just too far and
how do you support yourself now
um
well i do freelance writing
and then um i saw things on facebook
marketplace
um
i paint and sometimes i still some
paintings um i sell sometimes my son's
old clothes
my partner he does he has a heating
cooling business but he doesn't do it
very often um
and
so and then my mother she received
social security so
what was what's been your lowest point
um
when my kids got taken
yeah
and then
um about a year ago the ladies was
downstairs and um
the older lady
um when i asked for a cigarette okay
well when i had my son in 2020 um i
thought that my partner and i were good
you know i was really in love with him
and he had been messing around with her
daughter
and
then she called cps on me that the girl
did and
that probably hurt more than anything
because
we've always had each other you know 11
years you know
and then for him to be considering one
day i woke up he'd stole my drugs and he
was at this girl's house for 12 hours
people have told me
um
i don't think that he if he had a other
place to go i don't think he would be
with you i don't you know if he had
another place to live he wouldn't be
with you
people have told me that he has feelings
for her
um
i haven't always been best girlfriend
but you know i came to a point where i
was like if i say i'm committed i need
to honor that and i've really really
tried to do that
he's gone every night currently
every night
and then he tells me
you know he lost straight to my face
there so i have no idea what to believe
you know
but yeah listen losing when your best
friend
gets a new best friend it sucks and then
you realize that you know
like you love somebody
sucks to love somebody that doesn't love
you you know
but i have my son you know and and
what what's what were the best times of
your life best times in my life um
well uh winter when we first got to we
when 2011 my daughter was about to
we would take trips we have a cabin in
pendleton county we would go up there
central rocks
great times you know
um we lived in parkersburg for quite a
while we were completely off drugs when
we lived there
you know um
so those are about probably about the
best times yeah
do you feel like the
the sexual abuse you went through when
your mom was
selling you or whatever you want to call
it when you were young do you think
that's affected you as an adult
sure yeah
um and then my old man he it's like he
i don't know it's sometimes you know i
have changed you know i don't i
i don't haven't done that that stuff in
a long time
but
it makes you have no self-worth you know
have you have you worked
yeah in that form as an adult oh no no
no no thank
god and i don't like attention that's
the thing like i hate attention you know
i i just see myself as a nerdy tomboy
deep down and actually
yesterday
i walked out to get my mom's medicine
and i was coming back and this old man
75 plus
said you need a ride and i said sure
because i was tired of walking it was
hot you know
anyway i get in the car and he was like
i was just wondering if he was out
looking for a job and i was like yeah i
am he said you like sex this guy has an
oxygen tank and i said uh no
but i mean like sometimes i feel like i
just put up this wrong vibe or something
i don't i don't know you know
but uh no no thank god i haven't thank
god
what are you worried about in your life
now
um
[Music]
providing my sonic of life
you know i i don't want him my daughter
sadie
she's 12.
she saw some things you know um
or well i was selfish in my addiction
with her
with him
uh when i brought him home i made the
decision that because i looked into
adoption and things that i had to put
him first you know
and um i i fear losing him
because of you know where i live people
talk you know because i because of my
past everyone is always going to blame
the addict you know what i mean
and i'm afraid of losing him for
something stupid or
you know not that i haven't fought it
before but
that and um
i have some mental problems and i'm
alone every night so that that's not
helping
um
and i'm afraid if if
my mom my mother's just schizophrenic
and i'm afraid of
i'm afraid of turning out like that
oh thank you
but you know i i
generally try to see the positive and
everything you know
and so
you know this too shall pass it's not
what we face it's it's not the the
obstacles we face it's how we react to
them you know
so
what emotions do you go through now you
depressed um yeah you're depressed
and i worry a lot
the mother she puts a lot of worry on me
um
i uh
i feel guilty
for
you know um not
you know my son i don't know it's a
different mother than my other children
did and that's just not fair to them
but unfortunately i can't go back and
change it you know and because i haven't
seen my children anymore in three years
my other team there's always guilt and
shame
yeah absolutely it's gotta be hard
do you have hope for your future i mean
do you think you'll get clean one day
absolutely i have to i mean i that's the
only
way i have a future you know i've been
there done that and obviously it's not
working for me you know i'm tired of
that i don't go out at night i don't
because i want to be home with my son
you know before i would get pretty
messed up you know
there was times where i'd wake up and
couldn't tell you what happened the
night before and now i want to be
conscious and aware you know because i
guess after you lose something you
really appreciate it more
um
and
i mean if it weren't for my son
i don't i don't know where i'd be
i'd probably answer that question
completely different
so
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life when you were younger
um i still do yeah good answer how old
are you i'm 34. yeah you're still young
enough to do anything you want i'd like
to eventually be a lawyer one day it's
good for you
do you think being in this region where
addiction is drug addiction is so pop
you know so prevalent
is a problem yes i have to get out of
here
if i'm going to succeed in life i have
to get away from here i have to take my
son out of here what is the problem with
this area um
i think it's just there's so much um
poverty and so you get down on yourself
you know and there's nothing else to do
you know
and there's a lot of
abuse and trauma that we all go through
in this area
and
we band together to self-medicate
you know
yeah
so
it's it's such a beautiful area and yet
it's so
tragic at the same time it
is it's it's sad yeah it's quite an
oxymoron it really is what uh what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
um
[Music]
family's everything
you know but um you know and just
because
you are an addict you know i could be
clean ten years and i'll still be an
addict
but that doesn't have to define me
you know excellent
all right amber thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck thanks thank you
you